once your are you able to tell what
depth you're at is there any way to yeah
I should be I'm telling them earlier on
this one unfortunately we remove the
depth sensor to designer going
maintenance but the depth would be read
out right there and the vertical speed
how fast we're moving during water
column is right below how does it how
does it calculate because obviously the
tether it's so how good by the pressure
yeah well there's a little pressure
sensor that's on the bottom the same one
that you find in like a dive computer
okay and basically it measures pressure
as well as temperature which respects
what that pressure relates how that
relates to drown not yet but we liked it
as an accessory I picture it being an
acoustic device that would be sort of
omnidirectional looking in front of the
vehicle as well as below another really
important thing is altitude when you're
flying a transect you know you want to
be able to know how far you are if the
bottom starts going down you can go down
with it so we're under the pier right
now yeah right now we're here under the
pier at fort mason and we're looking at
what looks to be a lot of muscles
hanging down from the pilings as well as
some types of seaweed and algae looks
like her there's a crab earlier there
was a crowd on the bottom for the
elusive crabs but you use a little bit
you crabby yeah I've seen yeah the
tether Google engineers are more depth
capabilities when we do
so that's still five times deeper than
memorizing no no it's gone we're not
using a GoPro here you could just add
one if you want the extent I mean
wherever the vehicle goes the camera
sending the video up though oh I see
well in this water apparently four or
five inches it has light but what really
is a problem often musselshell there
it's just yeah its visibility in general
we do have some really advanced software
working on that might even be able to
help that a little bit but for the most
part I look at that view that's so
beautiful for the most part you're just
limited by exactly we were just flying
in Monterey this weekend and it was
beautiful you can see so far as doing it
off the land that you're going out on
foot we could this weekend we just
launched right off the pier and so we
got a whole bunch of tourists who came
by and got to fly in those early